We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P.. I invite you. Yes. You
to call anytime if you want to call it 4:00
in the morning. As many people do, go ahead
and call it 4:00 in the morning or call at
a more normal time. Here is a voicemail asking
really a pretty important question about what
will Republicans do about Trump if Trump loses
in November?
He did it. I feel like we don't talk enough
about how if Trump loses, it's going to be
tweeting from the sidelines constantly. And
I'm curious your thoughts. You think his base
will still hold him up as a guard? If you
think members of Congress will be influenced
by him or if they're just going to skirt,
it just happened. Good morning. I'm curious
your thoughts.
I think it is ultimately going to depend.
That's a good question. If Trump loses, but
he just keeps tweeting, tweeting, tweeting,
and he has a presence and he's on Fox News.
What will actual elected Republicans do? Will
they still sort of give deference to Trump
and listen to Trump or will they denounce
him? I think it will likely be neither. I
think the most likely scenario is if Donald
Trump loses and ultimately he will go, he
will resist it. He will claim it's rigged,
but ultimately he will go. My sense is, yes,
Donald Trump will keep tweeting. Yes, Donald
Trump will continue to be interviewed on.
Maybe it'll be Fox News. Maybe he'll shift
to O.J. and maybe he will start his own right
wing network of some kind. My instinct is
Republicans will not widely denounce Trump,
but they'll sort of pretend it never happened.
Remember how George W. Bush was not a big
part at all of John McCain's 2008 campaign
because George W. Bush was very unpopular
and polarizing. Donald Trump is ten times
more than that. So my expectation would be
that there would be a lot of sort of pretending
the last four years didn't happen. If Donald
Trump loses and I do not see it as likely
that Trump will shut up. I think that he will
continue to use Twitter and platforms because
he's narcissistic and he's desperate for attention
all the time. We have a great bonus show for
you today. I will tell you and Pat will tell
you what we have planned for our upcoming
staff vacation. We are going to be on vacation
next week. The show is not being canceled.
We are going to be back more powerfully than
ever, probably with a million YouTube subscribers.
After that vacation. But we are taking next
week off. We will talk about what we're going
to do. We will talk about this totally bogus
nomination Trump received from a far right
Norwegian politician for the Nobel Peace Prize.
We will talk about the AstraZeneca vaccine
trial being paused. And some people are making
a way bigger deal out of this than it actually
is. So we're going to talk about that. And
also very interesting news from the field
of is it archeology? Egyptian authorities
discovered 13 completely sealed. Twenty five
hundred year old coffins.
Super interesting news. We will talk about
the implications and much more on today's
bonus show. How do you get access to the bonus
show? It's easy. It's really, really easy.
You go to join Pacman dot com. That's w w
w dot join Pacman dot com. And you sign up.
That's it. It takes under a minute and you
can use the coupon code. This is 2020 to save
66 percent off of your membership. Actually,
no, I'm sorry. This is 2020. Saves you 40
percent. It's still good.
If you want to save 66 percent, the coupon
code is 20, 20 now, 20, 20 now. I will see
you on the bonus, Jeff.